after the sudden and unexpected storm
the surge for missing bodies
[Music]
said he was able to pull out his mother
and one girl before the mud avalanche
hit his bar
everything fell at once i never thought
i would see something like this
lost a niece and her niece's daughter
she's still looking for both
and has lost hope
yesterday a man was found alive in the
debris the firefighters pulled him out
today in the morning and he was dead i
can't cope with this anymore
carla
says she's come to pick up clothes and
food to take to the shelter where she's
sleeping but like many she has not yet
come to terms with her loss
i cannot go back to my house because
it's unsafe i lost the needs in the
mudslide but many have lost so much more
the number of deaths has been growing by
the hour after tuesday's unexpected
rainfall
230 millimeters of rain in three hours
the same amount expected for the whole
month
it submerged streets and destroyed
houses and vehicles
26 members of my family are alive but i
have lost all my friends they were
buried by the mud says
always
petropolis is also known as a summer
getaway for brazil's royalty when the
largest south american country was an
empire
the region suffered devastating floods
and mudslides in 2011
that killed more than 900 people
seventy-five-year-old gerald jomida says
he survived the first tragedy
but is homeless again
nothing was done to prevent this from
repeating itself
[Music]
climate change and geography may explain
part of the tragedy in petropolis but
there is much more says luis claudio
viera
poverty is also an issue
it's very difficult to check if houses
are being built irregularly if all rules
are being complied with when there's no
alternative to house the poor and needy
brazil's president jay bolsonaro tweeted
from russia he said he'll visit
petropolis on friday elections in brazil
are due later this year and recent polls
show bolsonaro trailing behind former
presidency lula da silva
the devastation in petropolis is only
expected to add to his rules monika
yanakev al-jazeera